The entertainers, they're using citizens
to give them success, to give them the
music, to to draw people to them.
>> Your father was a very high up voodoo
priest.
>> If they would come to my father and say,
"I want to make this music and I want it
to be successful." He would tell them
things to say in their music that would
then invite the demons into their music
>> and that would capture the people. How
how much do these people really know
what they're getting into?
>> I know that people have probably seen
those clips of Johnny Depp and uh
>> Johnny Depp
>> Johnny Depp talking about he's got 30
different people inside of him. Kiana
Ree,
>> Kiana Reeves,
>> Morgan Freeman,
>> Morgan Freeman. I mean, there's been a
lot of celebrities. Leardo DiCaprio,
they've talked about that. Um, but um I
don't think people realize how deep it
goes. I mean, it's not just acting, it's
sports, it's music, it's there's a lot
of things.
>> Tom Brady talked about Tom Brady.
>> His wife is a witch. Katy Perry's like,
"I sold my soul to the devil."
>> Yeah. It's happening everywhere. There's
been people that have come out and and
and talked about um the voodoo that
actually their stores and there's people
from Beyonce's family showed up. There
was a warlock, right, who saw who worked
there and who saw Beyonce's sisters come
in for some witchcraft.
>> I saw a weird article recently where
Leonardo DiCaprio was talking about the
one thing he can't do while method
acting.
>> Do you know what it is?
>> Pray.
>> Smoke weed.
>> Smoke weed. Oh, interesting. That isn't
weird. He actually said he can't do
that.
>> Yeah. He says if he smokes weed, it he
can't do it.
>> Throws it all off.
>> Yeah.
>> You know who else does method acting?
>> Jonathan Roomie from The Chosen.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm just saying. And if you understand
method acting, there's some ties to the
Jesuits and there's some ties to some
spiritual things right there.
>> There's a lot of people that do that.
>> Something else that's interesting. Um
Nicholas Cage. Yes.
>> When he played uh what was that film
with the
>> with the guy on the motor? Yeah. Ghost
Rider with the flames. Yeah,
>> he actually talked about the fact that
he went to South America,
>> went to a village way out in the middle
of nowhere and spent and he didn't
elaborate on how much time in the
article I read,
>> but he talked about that when he was
there, he found this shaman, which is
>> a priest or a witch doctor.
>> And he told him, I want to learn about
your spiritual connection, your
spiritual powers. So, what I would do is
I put on AfroCaribbean paint, like a
white and black paint, and black out my
eyes so I look like this sort of
AfroCaribbean voodoo icon, and then I
would sew in bits of Egyptian artifacts
that were thousands of years old into my
costume and gather some onyx or termine
or something that was meant to have
vibrations. And who knows if it works or
doesn't, but for me it was an idea of
like trying to stimulate my my mind or
trick my mind into believing I was this
this character from another dimension.
>> So it's real. They know their spiritual
power. They just don't realize that the
power they're serving is going to cost
them their life. And the power we're
serving is like so much higher.
>> Yeah. So, speaking of witch doctors and
voodoo priests, we have Lauren Duncan
here with us and Eric Wilson.
>> And I'm neither one.
>> Lauren,
>> I'm not a witch doctor or a voodoo
priest.
>> Was not making that making that
suggestion.
>> No. So, so Lauren, you are here with us.
You were with us on a different episode
where you shared your full testimony.
Your father before he passed away was a
very high up voodoo priest. And what
we're talking about here with all the
spiritualism and demonic stuff and
inviting spirits in, your father
actually had people come to him to make
sacrifices to Lucifer in order to get
stuff done such as you know acting and
there are politicians who came to him
even from the United States and there
were um you know people from the Super
Bowl coming to to make sure that the
outcome was a certain way, right? and
you are now a Christian and at the time
when you wanted to be set free yourself
from you know all this demonic stuff you
were talking to Eric Wilson and your
background is that you are had a were in
martial arts right and that in and of
itself is also very dark very demonic
and so you guys were in contact so we
brought you guys together to talk about
this but also to talk about if this is
true which I believe it is that movies
watching movies, acting in movies, um,
it opens doors to a darker world that if
you are dealing with these things and
letting something in, how you can also
be set free. So, Lauren, thank you for
coming on to the show.
>> Thank you for having me.
>> Yeah. And uh, c can you tell us a little
bit more about the the a brief synopsis
of what happened? Who was your father
and who came to visit him? So he was um
he was a very high up in the oult in um
in my in the Caribbean because people
came from other islands and came from
abroad, came from the US, came from
everywhere and they would come you know
to help. So we had politicians would
come, there would be um entertainers, um
music industry people and also people in
the sports world and also just regular
people. But um I didn't know that
I didn't know that people in
entertainment and sports
dabbled in that kind of thing. like if I
was not in that world, I would never
think that that is what um they did. And
so sometimes you will have athletes and
not saying there are not talented
athletes, they are. But a lot of times
these games um
football and and other sports, soccer
even,
>> a lot of times it's not it's not the
people, it's not the athletes that are
winning the game. there's actually
demons there that are coordinating
everything, you know, for them to win
and for them to win titles. And um I
think um the more
these athletes that are really on the
top and then stay winning all the time,
they know
what's going on. Like they're not
oblivious. Like they're not they're not
just thinking, "Oh, we're so great.
You're winning." They know why they're
winning. And so a lot of um a lot of
people came to my to my dad to to win
games and to win tournaments and to win
stuff like that. And entertainers came
so that they also can have um great
success in their fields, you know, in
what they were doing. And um so back
then when I was in there, I grew up that
way like um I grew up in training to do
what my father did actually.
And um
I didn't really I didn't I didn't really
take to it. Like I was in it. I didn't
know anything else but I didn't
I kept thinking that there was something
else and I wanted to do that something
else. I didn't know what it was but I
didn't want to be tied to that
lifestyle.
And even um while we did it, like we
were doing rituals, like we would be
doing really demonic things, but there
was always an open Bible there. Wow. And
it never Yeah. It never occurred to me.
We never read from it. Like I don't know
what the Bible said, but there was
always an open Bible. And I think now it
was for us to believe
that somehow God was in your way
>> and that's why the Bible was there
because I would always ask my mother is
this of God and she would say yes.
So um she would say God put you here to
do these things. And so I didn't
understand how we can um for instance
there were a lot of people homeless
people. There were a lot of um you would
say crazy people on the streets and a
lot of them were there because my father
put them there like of Yes. He would um
attach demons to them. And so then their
life would just go down and they would
be in the streets. They're dirty. They
look like crazy crazy people, but
they're there because he put them there.
And anytime he had to if he had
something he wanted to try out, like if
he if if the demons gave him a new way
to do something, he would he would walk
through the the town and he would he
would try out on these homeless people.
So, I mean, he was he was not a a really
he was a really demonic guy. like he
spoke face to face with Satan and I did
too. I mean, I thought I thought Satan
was my friend. I did, you know, I didn't
know God until
the Lord brought me out of that.
>> There's a verse in Proverbs 26:2. It
says, "As the bird by wondering, as the
swallow by flying, so the curse
causeless shall not come." what that
literally tells us as believers and not
just believers in but followers of the
Lord Jesus Christ.
>> That's why it's so important that our
lives are consecrated completely to God.
>> And I don't remember who it was, but I
remember hearing a pastor talking about
he was on an airplane one day and he had
asked the Lord for a divine appointment
on that flight. He said, "I want I want
to meet somebody that I can witness to."
The guy sitting next to him is there and
this this pastor is reading his Bible
and the man starts talking to him. Come
to find out the man is a witch. Like a
highlevel witch.
>> And he tells this pastor, he says, "You
know, you think there's power in reading
the, you know, that Bible, the word of
God." He said, "There's no power." He
said, "I can do whatever I want, you
know, and the Bible's not going to make
any difference."
>> And the pastor looked at him and the
pastor knew God. He knew Jesus Christ
personally. He said, "There's nothing
you can do that will affect me." And the
man said, "I can have you and your wife
divorced in so many weeks."
>> And the man said, "No, you can't. You
can't touch either one of us." And the
the man that was a witch, he said, "Let
me ask you a couple of questions." He
said,
>> "Do you watch these movies?" And the
pastor said, "No." He said, "Do you
listen to this kind of music, this
secular music?" The pastor said, "No, I
don't." He said, "Okay, do you do you
read these kind of books?" The pastor
said, "No, I don't." And finally, at the
end of the questions, the witch, the man
that was a witch, he looked at him, he
said, "You're right. I can't touch you."
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's like those no matter how
powerful somebody is in witchcraft, no
matter what spell or curse or hex or vex
or incantation they speak, we have
angels of God that excel in strength
that surround and protect us. And if we
are consecrated to God, which is easy to
do, follow him. obey him, trust him.
When we do that, the no no weapon that
is formed against us can prosper.
>> You know, it's interesting that you say
that because um there was a time when I
I had been a Christian for for many
years and you know, in the beginning of
your Christian walk, you like this and
at some point without you realizing it,
it's like the frog in the pot thing,
right? Slowly you become more lukewarm.
>> Yeah.
>> And I started watching a lot of YouTube.
I got addicted to YouTube and I noticed
this is like a few years in I started
getting demonic oppression and attacks
and I just didn't realize I didn't make
the connection between me and
technically what I did is I had a false
god in my life because every time I felt
stressed or I felt I had a heavy day I
didn't go to Jesus I wanted the quick
fix so I went to YouTube and I noticed
once that stopped and I gained the
victory. I'd only noticed months later.
Oh, it hasn't happened in a while. Amen.
>> Where did it go? Where's the demonic
oppression? And it left me. And I hadn't
even made the connection. I remember
praying about it. Lord, would you take
this away? Would you protect me? I don't
want this. But once I actually got rid
of the idol in my life that was putting
the idol, the the YouTube, the amount of
time I spent on it before God, and mind
you, I wasn't watching anything on
kosher. It was the time that I was
spending on it and and then me, you
know, putting that thing before God that
opened a door to the demonic spirits.
Even though I was spending time in my
Bible and doing all these things, you
know, it was me choosing to open that
door and and once God helped me to close
it, everything was gone. So, I totally
see what you mean.
>> And one of the things also I want to say
is there were times when we would do um
a novena. Do you know what a novena is?
>> That's the Catholic prayer, isn't it?
>> Yeah. So, we would go is like a
procession and you would go from like
church to church to church, Catholic
churches, and we would light candles and
we would pray to the saints.
>> Interesting.
>> If we wanted like if we wanted something
done, we would also go and pray to the
saints to um to do stuff for us. I mean
now I know that that was the saints
there you know that's demonic but at the
time we would join those Catholic
processions and we would we would go do
this from church to church like in one
whole day we go to like nine different
uh churches and say you know nine set we
nine sets of uh praying to different uh
saints all throughout the day and then
and the thing would happen like Whatever
you were praying for it would happen.
So, so now you believed
that there was power in praying to say
it's the same way the Catholic could.
>> The novena is appears in the Hallow app,
the Catholic prayer meditation app. And
we actually did a whole episode on that
with how it has strong ties to the
Jesuits, which is a secret society that
really was designed created to turn
Protestants back toward um Catholicism.
And yeah, that whole app is like that as
well. And they also have the novena app
uh novena prayer in that. So, it's
interesting that you mentioned that that
you guys were voodoo uh you know,
people, priests, and this is what you
guys were doing.
Now, do do you um attend church
regularly or is um when you are kind of
on on the voodoo side of things like um
you're not interacting with churches at
all or how how are you kind of going and
doing these like prayer walks with other
church members? Well, we didn't attend
regularly, but I besides being um in the
oult, I was raised Catholic. So, I went
to Catholic school and um I was involved
in in uh you know the stuff that you do,
you do first communion and then whatever
else. But and and my mother was um
she was Nazerie
and she was Nazarene which is kind of
like Catholic the same. So if we ever
had to go to church or anything um it
would absolutely be a Catholic church
because there were a lot of similarities
in what we were doing and what they were
doing. So, and it we just thought that
um there was nothing wrong with going to
church and doing this because it was
kind of the same.
Um
>> yeah, especially especially in the the
South American countries and um
>> yeah, a lot of times it's it's equated
as being you can have both.
>> Yes. Because even after I came out of it
one time, I saw a a guy there. He was a
visitor and he came and um and he came
to the church and he was do when it came
time to get up and greet,
you know, greet people. He was greeting
them with the handshake that we did in
the in the oult.
>> Yes. And I I I kept looking at like I
forgot all about greeting everyone
because I kept staring at him like I
could not believe that he was he was
doing it. And but he wasn't there to
serve the Lord. He was there my
the impression I had he wasn't there to
serve the Lord. He was there to really
try to
spread his darkness
around, you know, to the to anybody in
the congregation. And to this day, I
feel like I should have went to him and
said and said something. I I didn't, but
I was so shocked. I just stood there
because I was new in in in the faith.
But it just let me know that you can
you're not safe anywhere. If you're not
serving the Lord, if you're not obeying,
if you're not saying, if you're not
doing what the Lord wants you to do,
you're not safe. Because I can say I I
go to church but where I found in my own
life
before I stopped watching music videos
and those things I would watch music
videos on YouTube in my head I'm
watching romantic songs and love songs
and those things but stuff would start
happening at home
and
then it would dawn on me you open that
or by the music that you're that you're
listening to. So, little by little, I
realized I had to close all of these
doors. Like,
these doors are still, you're still
opening yourself up to satanic things
with them because the entertainers
are using
Satan. They're using citizen to to give
them success to give them the music to
to draw people to them and um and then
if they come if they would come to my
father
and say you know I want to make this
music and I want it to be successful he
would tell them things to say in their
music
>> that would then
invite the demons into
their music. Wow.
>> And that would capture a people.
>> So then
they're helping each other because my
father was giving them things to say and
now that would make them successful. But
then the things that they're saying, the
people that are listening to it are now
opening themselves up to Satan. So the
both sides are gaining something from
it.
>> And that's exactly what Satan wants. He
wants to use humans in order to spread
the lies and deception that he's doing.
>> So, how much do these people that came
to your father, how much did they really
know what they were getting themselves
into? um for example because you thought
that Satan was your friend and I've
understood from Roger Mano who you know
he's passed away now but he was a former
Satanist turned Christian that a lot of
people really believe that Lucifer is
eventually going to win the battle
between him and Satan him and Jesus and
that he is going to basically allow
everybody to live forever however they
want and so how how much do these people
really know what they're getting into a
lot of people, a lot of them
that are seasoned,
they know what they're doing,
>> right?
>> And because
because a lot of time it's like a
competition
between them, like I'm talking about the
entertainers.
>> Gotcha.
Um, you would have to have a lot of them
would have demons assigned to them and
they know this because they felt like
they had to have some protection because
the other person that wants to want to
be more successful than you are,
it's like a competition between them. So
a lot of them
they know and they would you can tell
you can tell by
stuff that they wear or jewelry that
they have and even today I can go
somewhere I'm not in that life anymore
but I can see something that you're
wearing the symbolism on it
um on your jewelry.
I know that you know what you're doing.
So a lot of them they know that but it's
it's just greed. It's just I want
this now on this earth at this time.
This is what I want. And so they know
that that's what they do it and they're
somehow convinced that they'll still
come out okay at the end or
when I'm ready I can get out of it. But
you really really cannot. I mean, you
can if you if the Lord can set you free,
but on your own, you can't just say,
"Okay,
>> it's all about Jesus.
>> Walk away now." Because even when the
Lord brought me out of it, it was 1990
98. I did not meet Eric until 2015.
>> So, I was not completely free.
>> Wow.
>> Until Eric gave me all of those uh
verses of scripture.
>> Amen. for
that's a long time between 98 and 2015 I
was still struggling I was still having
um visitations I was still having uh I
was still so heavily oppressed
by it until the until until Eric told me
you're you're free you just don't know
that you're free
>> and so
you know you can be free but you have to
you have to choose Well, you know, it's
it's amazing like you you you
see them like fighting against each
other and trying to have supremacy even
in their own ranks and it's like no
peace, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> You really do see that when you come to
God and you truly adhere to God's
principles, I mean, there is a peace
that he's offering that that passes all
understanding. I mean, it's like a
>> it's like a different different
different way. and even even in their,
you know, fighting for whatever scraps
that they can get of this world, right?
It's like, is it is it really like like
even close to compared to what's being
offered you?
>> Oh, no. I
>> I'm not I kind of wonder if it's really
fighting for scraps of this world as
much as it is. They're they're still in
the mindset of war.
>> That's a good point. And they
are each in their own individual, right?
Each one of those demons is trying to be
God.
>> Mhm.
>> And so
>> like above Lucifer even you think
>> above Satan.
>> I mean
>> Yeah. I mean I think that spirit own
each one when you separate from God
essentially you are trying to be God.
And it doesn't matter if there's
>> a bigger batter angel or whatever demon
you are trying to be God. So I see them
as essentially trying to control
>> other demons or other people as their
way of playing God.
>> So like whatever demon has access to the
highest uh actor or or musician. Maybe
that's like their way of saying like I'm
the top dog.
>> Yeah. I own you.
>> Right. you know, some something I'm just
going to kind of go back just a little
bit where she was talking about, you
know, the question about, you know, do
people really understand what they're
getting involved with? A lot of times at
the beginning steps, they may not, but
as she said, somebody that's been in
this,
>> and I remember, and you guys have seen
this, you've even shown this on some of
your your videos before,
>> remember the interview that 60 Minutes
did with Bob Dylan?
>> Yes.
>> Why do you still do it? Why are you
still out here? Well, it goes back to
the destiny thing. You know, I made a
bargain with it, you know, long time
ago, and I'm holding up my end.
>> What was your bargain
>> to get where um I am now?
>> He said, "I'm holding up my end of the
bargain." Well, he knows he has to.
That's what he feels because the demons
are telling you, "If you don't do what
you committed to doing, we're going to
kill you or we'll kill your family
members."
>> Yeah. But the thing is is is that when
you surrender to Christ,
>> that's null and void. Every contract
you've made with the devil is null and
void.
>> You know, praise God. It's like, look at
the two demoniacs in the Bible. These
guys were naked.
>> They had broke the chains that the
town's people had put them in. They're
cutting themselves. You know, they had
to be perverts cuz they're running
around with no clothes on, cutting
themselves.
>> And you know what? Jesus set them free.
And it was like that day they were a new
creation.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, we gotten we well we had some
feedback um I remember about the Bob
Dylan bit saying that that was taken out
of context
>> and that he was really um you know he
wasn't referring to Satan, he was
referring to God.
And I guess what I would say to that is
I I question that because
when
>> all you have to do is look at the fruit
of the life, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And so with Bob Dylan
>> copious amounts of drugs like he's
admitted to that copious amounts of
drugs.
>> Mhm.
>> And you could say, well, you know, that
was in the past. That's a long time ago.
But he also has or started
>> his own brand of hard liquor. Do you
know what it's called?
heaven's door.
>> Oh wow.
>> For whiskey
>> and you know other bourbon and and those
kind of things. And that was the reason
it's 2018.
>> So does God
>> bless somebody to create
>> addictive substances that destroys
people's lives,
>> destroys families
>> and all that. Is is that what God made a
deal for so he could make his own brand
of, you know, alcohol to sell to people?
>> No. God doesn't do that.
>> Does Sa would Satan do that? Absolutely.
Satan would do that.
>> God doesn't do that.
>> If people saw the entire interview with
Bob Dylan, there's no question about who
he was talking about. And I always
wonder too, Lauren, I don't know, maybe
you can speak to this a little bit more,
but um you know, as a Satanist or
somebody that's that's sort of
advocating for that side, would they get
on Christian YouTube channels and
comment, you know, like just to try to
discredit or like I always wonder
sometimes when people are advocating for
that, like are you really a Christian?
Because I don't think most Christians
would probably say it.
>> H there's plenty of Christians who watch
all kinds of things and do want to
defend it.
>> Yeah,
>> I think Yeah. In Christianity, there's a
lot of self-justification.
>> Yeah,
>> that's a good Yeah, that's a good point.
>> Because we try to justify our own
actions, our own sin.
>> It's it's how we don't feel, you know,
guilt and shame and all that kind of
stuff. But if you don't feel all that,
then you don't see your need of Jesus.
And that's a very dangerous place to be.
>> That's true.
>> Yeah. And it's the same as if like so we
see that example in in Lauren's life,
for example, and and that's that's an
amazing testimony of how God set you
free. We see it with Roger Monno and we
see it with many other people who are
former Satanists. We see it with uh Rob
Lang who was the producer for P. Diddy.
Yeah. You know, he was he's a pastor
now.
>> Um but you know, we also see it with
people that might consume media. We've
done an episode with David where he
talked about horror movies and how it's
really an open door for for the demons
to come in. But Jesus sets people free.
People Jesus always sets you free if you
if you want to. if you really want to.
And
>> I want to say it's not just horror
movies. I mean,
>> that's right.
>> True.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Because people will think about,
well, if I don't watch horror movies,
you know, I'm I'm I'm okay. But it's
really not just horror movies. Like you
can it can be any type of movie that is
that is not
is not glorifying the is not made on um
glorifying the Lord or something like
that. Yeah. So, anything else? I mean,
you can watch you can watch a a kids
movie.
>> Yes.
>> And you can open the door to Satan in
your house. You can um your you you open
your kid. You're giving them um a
doorway to your to your child. I mean, I
I I'm I'm constantly
thinking about that because I have a
grandson and um I'm, you know, I'm I'm
always on that like, you know, I don't
wanted to watch anything because you
never know like it's not just horror. I
mean, he was there was a kids uh
program. It was specifically for kids
and it was about car racing,
but he's fascinated with cars. So, he
always likes to look at things that has
to do with cars. It's not cartoons. It's
like real life car racing. But they put
together this thing for kids, but they
named
the cars have all different kinds of
names. And this one car, they named it
Satan. go.
>> And so he's watching this courage and
the person is saying, "Go Satan, go. Go
Satan." And I'm like,
>> "What is this?" And you know, so it's
it's it's not just horror. It's anything
any means that Satan can get in
>> the door. You'd probably be shocked at
how many like random kids programs and
stuff like this probably do this kind of
stuff just to get ahead. Yeah,
>> I mean it's it's probably quite a lot
more than you'd be uh be be shocked to
hear
>> or put a lot of adult jokes in.
>> That's true. Ju just adding Lauren to
what you were talking about with the
movies and how I would say majority of
movies can probably open the door. Um I
remember I think it was Scott Ritzma's
media on the brain series that I was
listening to or watching and he was
making references to many actors who
said, "Oh yeah, this movie right here.
Yeah. So, I channeled this spirit who
played that character. And the movie was
the most wholesome movie you could
possibly imagine.
>> So, it's not even about the topic. It's
about who are they channeling. Um,
>> that was like Little House on the
Prairie, Michael Landon. He was actually
communicating with his dead father to
help him write some of the scripts
>> for Little House on the Prairie and for
some of his after, you know, shows that
people thought were Christian.
>> Same with Andrew Garfield, who played in
Hacksaw Ridge. He played Desmond Doss
who was a very devout Christian man who
risked his life to save other people and
they made a movie about him. I watched
Hacksaw Ridge and I was thinking man I
have not seen anything gory this gory in
a very long time and and I was like okay
but I was like well the message was
good. Well, turned out that he went to
visit Desmond's uh uh house or prayer
site or grave site, sorry, something
like that
>> form too. Walk around his form,
>> touched his tools and start speaking to
Desmond Doss and asking him like help me
to do this.
>> We were talking about mystery earlier
and how the and the process of absorbing
Desmond's essence and attempting to
ingest him. So I so I stay in the accent
all the time to not confuse myself
mostly.
>> It was the depth of soul. Uh there's
also u I think he wasn't a talker
Desmond and Andrew is able to convey
very much without the need of dialogue
as an actor. I mean you can just see
into his eyes and stuff. It's all going
on.
So I mean I his talents I think I mean
very talented just suited this character
and then I wasn't disappointed at all.
He's managed to inhabit Desmond or
Desmond inhabited him. I'm not sure
which. I think there was some both going
on. that there was a a particularly
profound moment where I went to um
Chattanooga, Tennessee, which is where
Desmond eventually retired and passed
away. And I went onto his old property
um and went into his his old wood
woodshed and handled his tools and
walked around the lake that he would
walk around. And it was I spent a day
there just kind of praying and and and
asking like just guide me through this.
If you can hear me, tell me tell me what
to do. Tell me how to move, tell me how
to speak, tell me how to behave, and
I'll do whatever you say. So that there
was some there there was a a strange
mysterious spirituality
going on around the the making of
>> and same with Jonathan Ruby.
>> This is a Facebook post visiting St.
Padre Peio, one of the most powerful
saints and witnesses to the suffering
and the miracles of Christ in the 20th
century as well as one with whom I had
personal interaction
>> and saying that he has had personal
interactions with this saint who died
before this guy was even born. This is
straight up necromancy. This is
forbidden in the Bible because you
cannot communicate with the dead.
>> All right, so there's Christianity and
then there's spiritualism. A Christian
is someone who follows Christ, the
resurrection and the life. A
spiritualist, well, they seek to
communicate with spirits of the dead.
And those two belief systems cannot
blend together. One of the main reasons
is because God himself specifically
tells his followers to stay away from
spiritualism, even going to the point of
saying that those who engage in it, they
will not inherit the kingdom of God.
>> He actually went and sought out where
Lonnie Frisbee was buried. And this was
scary what he did.
>> Before I started work, I went over to
Christ Cathedral and uh I I sat by his
grave and I prayed a rosary with him. I
sat down and I prayed with him. Um there
this the space just to his right is
empty. So I got to sit down or lie at
one point I even lied down because I
just thought it would be kind of
interesting to try to connect in some
way. That's probably more information
than you need or may even want to
publish. But that said, uh I you know I
it's the truth. And so I finished
praying with him and I said, "Lonnie, I
want to honor you with this film
and I really want to um to to to bring
justice and and you know, the testament
to the gifts of God's grace and and
powers that you've you know displayed
while you were on this earth. And so
if this is a good idea that I do this
film,
have somebody give me a sign. Give me a
sign. Have God give me a sign. And the
minute the words left my mouth
behind me, there was a door open to the
cathedral and this giant cord rang out
for about 5 seconds and then
>> from the organ.
>> From the organ.
>> Wow.
>> I hadn't heard it before. And that's the
very organ that used to be there when it
was the C. It's the same organ that when
it was the Crystal Cathedral. It was
sent out and refurbished and whatnot,
but it's the same one.
>> So, I heard that and I was like,
"Okay,
thanks for that."
>> When you're asking and you know, and
you're not asking God, you're asking a
dead person. You're literally telling
the spirit world, "Hey, I want you to
show me something. Show me something
that's going to convince me." And he got
that answer when he heard the organ
play. He was like, "All right, thank you
for that." Who was he thanking? He
wasn't thinking a dead man. He's been
dead for years. But he was actually
thanking the demons that gave him the
sign. Jesus actually said that it's an
adulterous and wicked nation that looks
for signs and wonders.
>> He was graveing, right? So he would
grave soak all of these um uh Catholic
saints and which basically means you're
laying on the grave and like absorb
something. So absorb the dead.
>> Demons what you're absorbing.
>> Exactly.
>> That's there's nothing else more than
demons.
>> Yes.
I mean demons uh you know one thing that
they they they love to impersonate um
your dead relatives or or dead somebody.
>> Uh it's so it's so perfect
like you absolutely believe that that's
the person that you're talking to. Like
there's
there's there's there's nothing you can
say is off about how they look, how they
talk, how they act. It's it's so
perfect. And a lot of people believe
that
I'm really talking to to to my mother or
to my
>> right,
>> to whoever it is. And then
it's it's all demonic. I mean, I
talk to my father. I thought it was my
father after he died.
>> You know, I didn't know any any any
difference. And
it's very sad how many people
that really think that they're serving
the Lord with all their heart and soul,
but they still talk to somebody that's,
you know, in their life that's passed,
but it's not. It's it's it's it's a
complete demon you're talking to. So, so
Lauren and Eric, I kind of want to shift
this conversation a little bit.
If people are dealing with demonic
possession, oppression,
whether it's from movies, whether it's
from entertainment, whether it's from
anything else, both of you guys have
dealt with this. How can you be set free
through Jesus?
Um, I want to go back to what Lauren
said and I I remember when I watched the
interview that you did with the hope and
heritage uh with the men there and
Denique, you were there and it was like
I was watching it and that one statement
that you made it was like it was so
powerful and I know it wasn't you, it
was the spirit of the living God that
was speaking through you, but you she
was talking about how she had contacted
us and I'm nobody. Um,
But she said that I told her, "You're
already free. You just don't know it."
>> And a lot of times we don't,
>> the devil loves to make things
complicated.
>> And it's not complicated.
>> Jesus said in John 8:32, he said, "You
shall know the truth, and the truth will
make you free." Not set you free, make
you free. And you know when you look up
the word truth, it means the unfailing
verity of God's word, his promises.
So Satan, the word Satan means accuser.
Jesus said Satan is a liar. So Satan
lies to people and that's how he gets
them in bondage. Jesus tells them the
truth and when we believe the truth, we
can shake off the chains.
>> Amen. So, one of the things, um, I'm
going to give you just a couple of
verses. In Isaiah chapter 52, one of my
favorite verses, God is talking to each
of us individually. And he actually says
something in Isaiah 52. He says,
"Arise, arise, O Jerusalem. Shake
yourself from the dust." He's saying,
"You were dead in the grave. Get up out
of the grave." And then he says, "Loose
yourself from the bands of your neck, oh
captive daughter of Zion. You have sold
yourself for not, but you have been
redeemed without money."
>> Amen.
>> In John 8:36, Jesus says, "If the Son
therefore shall make you free, you are
free indeed,
>> you are free indeed."
>> So I sold myself for sin. And it wasn't
just martial arts. The martial arts was
the easy part. The sexual sin, the
rejection, the bitterness, that was much
more difficult to get free from than the
martial arts,
>> which all allows demons in as well. Even
those mindsets.
>> Yeah.
>> So, when an evil spirit comes into a
person's life, I'm not saying they're
possessed or or I'm just saying their
influence. When their influence comes
into a person's life,
>> they do everything they can to make
their thoughts become your thoughts.
>> Yep. And they usually when they talk to
to people, especially to people that
profess Christ, normally they talk to us
in our voice. So we will think the
thoughts are our own thoughts.
>> You're rejected. Nobody loves you. They
don't like you. You're fat. You're ugly.
Um you're bitter. You're you'll never
get over this sickness. They whisper
that. And as we hear that thought in our
mind, in our voice, we begin to believe
it. And then we do the worst thing. We
start giving voice to it.
>> We start speaking the lies that the
enemy is saying. What we've got to do is
speak what God's word says.
>> I am free because Christ made me free. I
sold myself for sin, but Christ took my
sins at Calvary. All of them.
>> Once we lay hold on that. And that was
what
what Lauren said. That was how God set
me free because I had all this um
I felt like Pilgrim in Pilgrim's
Progress. I'm trying so hard to get
free. And it's like when the Lord showed
that to me through the writings of a
couple of other people and through a
couple of people I talked with, they
were like, "Eric, you've already been
paid for. Do you believe that?"
>> Do you know? Um and forgive me, I'll
shut up here in a second. This is just I
get excited about this. Um,
Romans chapter 1:16,
>> the Apostle Paul says, "I am not ashamed
of the gospel of Christ." Not ashamed
means I believe in him. He's not going
to put me to shame.
>> If I tell my son, I'll be there to pick
you up at 5:00. I'm not going to not
show up. He knows my dad said he'll be
here, he'll be here. Paul says,"I am not
ashamed of the glad tidings of Christ."
Because the glad tidings of Christ is
the power of God unto salvation. And the
word salvation does not simply mean,
okay, you've got a ticket to get into
heaven. When you look the word up in its
Greek and in the Hebrew definitions,
there's a couple of Greek words, uh,
sotia and sodo, and then you've got a
couple of Hebrew words. When you look
those definitions up, the word salvation
includes deliverance,
rescue, freedom, physical healing,
mental healing, restoration.
>> That's what he came to give us. Now, not
just in heaven. God wants Hallelujah.
God wants to set us free if we will just
believe his word. And what happens is as
you start reading his word out loud and
putting your name into that promise,
>> Amen.
>> the walls of lies that this that the the
devil has put in our minds, those walls
just start coming down. It's like an
illusion and God sets us free.
>> Yes, that's exactly what happened to me.
I I I I wasn't free until I started
reading
those scriptures. And even though you
told me to read it out aloud, I started
reading them in my head at first. I
said, I don't have to say this out loud.
And I read them in my head. And nothing
changed.
Everything said exactly the same. And
then I was like, okay, fine. I will read
them out loud. And then I started
reading them out loud. And then the more
I read them, the more
I understood them. And then the more I
understood them, the more I believed
them.
>> Amen.
>> Believed it is when everything changed.
Wow.
>> God God tells us in Romans 10:17, "Faith
will come by hearing and hearing by the
word of God."
>> Amen.
>> It's powerful to hear. And that's why I
think to speak even um and share these
stories is powerful for people to hear
that you know and and you know these
these these demonic experiences. I mean
you read the Bible and you can see like
you know um when Peter uh you know said
something to Jesus and Jesus turned
around and said get behind me Satan. You
know, it's like
>> you're in the very presence of Jesus and
you're able to have,
>> you know, speaking the words of the
enemy.
>> Yeah. Satan Satan was influencing Peter
and Peter didn't even realize it.
>> Yeah. And and and you re you realize,
you know, the more that you read how God
works in the Bible, it's like you can
hear the language of how God works. He
he sets you free. He he delivers you.
He, you know, do does these things that,
you know, it's the devil that's the
discourager, right? Yeah.
>> You can't do this. You won't do this. It
won't get free. You won't be, you know,
>> able to do this. And and so, yeah, you
really you really benefit from speaking
that out loud. There's a powerful um
section in Acts 26
and mostly um the last part of it are
the words of Jesus where Jesus is
talking to Paul and Paul is recounting
his conversion story. It says, "Saul,
Saul, why are you persecuting me? It is
hard for you to kick against the goats."
So I said, "Who are you, Lord?" And he
said, "I am Jesus, whom you are
persecuting, but rise and stand on your
feet, for I have appeared to you for
this purpose to make you a minister and
a witness, both of the things which you
have seen and of the things which I will
yet reveal to you. I will deliver you
from the Jewish people as well as from
the Gentiles to whom I now send to open
their eyes in order to turn them from
darkness to light and the f power of
Satan to God that they may receive
forgiveness of sins and an inheritance
among those who are sanctified by faith
in me.
>> That's what God wants to do with each
one of us.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. When I was in um in darkness,
I used to think that
a lot of people, I would say a lot of
people, not me, but even like my mother
and people that I know, they don't
believe that they can get free because
Sith tells them
>> there's nothing else like you have to
you have to stay on this side. if you
leave, I will kill you or you will die
or stuff. And he told those things to me
and
but the Lord told me the truth.
>> Amen.
>> And so I'm not dead. This was how many
years ago? Like I'm alive and well. Um,
even at the time I was having my
daughter and he he told me, you know, I
would kill her.
She's alive and well. And this was 26
years ago. Um, that he was going to kill
her right then and there. And uh, you
know, she's alive and well because
because he is also he is subject to God.
He doesn't
>> Amen.
>> He doesn't want us to know that, but he
is subject to God. like he cannot like
the Lord puts a hedge around you and and
if God does not give him permission, he
can't do what he would like to do.
>> Amen.
>> So, you know, he's still telling lies.
He's still saying, "I will kill you. I
will do this to you." But he he cannot.
You know, the Lord the Lord set me free.
I am free indeed.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And so anybody in that in that
life if they want to be free they can.
>> Amen. Do
>> you know there's a promise in in Isaiah
42 and this is one of my favorites as
well. And you can claim this for your
family. You can claim it for somebody
even if you don't know them. If you just
see somebody that's struggling when
you're out shopping one day. It says I
will bring the blind by a way that they
knew not. I will lead them in paths that
they have not known.
>> I will make darkness light before them,
and I will make the crooked things
straight. These things will I do unto
them, and I will not forsake them. And
it's like, I know somebody had to be
claiming that for me as well as for you.
And I know somebody's claiming that, you
know, now for our children. We are like,
Lord, you made a promise. And God cannot
lie. It's not that he won't lie. He
can't because if he speaks something, it
is.
>> He said, "My word has gone forth. It
cannot return unto me void." When my
wife was praying for me for those almost
five years that I had divorced her and I
was living in adultery. My wife was
like, "I don't care what the people at
my church are saying. I don't care what
your doubt is. I know what God's word
says.
>> God said what God's word says. What I've
joined together, let no man put us
under." And there was a lady at our
church that told my wife, she said,
"Sarah, honey, the judge signed the
papers." And my wife said, "My God
didn't sign those papers." She said, "If
you don't believe, don't pray for me."
And she walked out.
>> She was like, "I'm going to stand on
God's word." And I'm learning now, even
in my own life, I have to do that with
physical health. I have to do that with
situations I'm dealing with. I've got to
say, "What does God's word say?" I stand
on the word of God. And I I'm I'm
encouraging our our viewers and our
listeners.
That's the one reason above every other
that Satan tries to lead us into sin.
Because when we commit a known sin, our
faith just gets taken out from
underneath of us. All of a sudden, you
don't you're not able to believe God's
word the way you could before you had
yielded to sin. So Satan is like, "If I
can just keep them falling, especially
with something they know is wrong, I can
undermine their faith." And without
faith, you can't do anything. You can't
even please God.
>> God wants us to be able to trust him and
believe in him.
>> Amen. Yeah. I remember Lauren when I
first heard your testimony when I was on
the previous recording at uh Heritage
and Hope Ministries and we aired it on
our channel, I was so encouraged. I was
like, "Wow, if God can set her free, the
daughter of a voodoo priest, a high
voodoo priest who you were trained to be
the next one in line." I was like, "If
God can set you free, he can set me
free. He can set anybody free." Amen.
>> And it was so so encouraging for me to
hear that. And I'm sure it's really
encouraging for other people, too.
>> Praise the Lord. That's what I'm hoping.
Anybody listening, there's still hope.
You can be free.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. So Lauren, I understand that so
your father's passed away, but your
mother is still alive and she needs
prayer, right? She does. She's um she
never let she never left the occult, but
now she is um she has advanced
Alzheimer's. So she she doesn't even
recognize me. Um she doesn't know us and
she doesn't she's not coherent. But I am
still asking the Lord to bind the demons
because I know a lot of it that she's
going through is demonic. And I'm asking
the Lord to bind those demons, you know,
that and allow the Holy Spirit to
convict her and allow her to accept
Christ, you know, before it's too late
for her. She's 82.
And um and so that's my prayer for her
every day. Tell tell us what her first
name is. What's her first name?
>> Yoland.
>> Okay. Then all of us, let's start
lifting her in prayer every day. And
let's claim let's claim the blood that
Jesus shed for her because Jesus died
for every human being that has ever
lived. Whether they know it or not.
>> They've already been paid for.
>> Amen.
>> She's one of those people that is
afraid. like when she was still in her
she was afraid that if she left you know
stuff would happen to her or to us. So
she never left partly because she was
afraid.
>> Can can you guys talk a little bit about
um generational curses and um you know
how to be freed from that?
>> There are generational curses that can
be passed. Um, and those curses can be
biblical curses. Like when you look in
the Bible, especially Deuteronomy 27,
28, 29, and 30, it talks about if a
person does such and such, they're
cursed by God for this. And that curse
is passed on.
What breaks that curse is faith in what
Christ did on Calvary. Because Galatians
3 10-14, it says Jesus um redeemed us
from the curse of the law. It doesn't
mean God's law is a curse. It means the
curses that were included in that law,
the penalties for transgression,
but there has to be faith. We've got to
believe that God's done it. Um,
>> Zephaniah 3 verse 14- 20, it says that.
It says Christ has redeemed us. It says
Christ has taken away our judgments. He
has cast out our enemy. What we have to
do as Christians is I go to the Lord
even if I've got ancestors that I don't
know what they did. I have no idea what
most of my ancestors might have been
involved in. But I can go to the Lord
even without knowing what their personal
sins are and say, "Lord, I'm confessing
the sins, the iniquities, and
transgressions of all my ancestors." You
know, and take it back as far as you
want to go back, however far the Lord
leads you. and say, "And I'm claiming
the blood of Jesus over those sins." Not
that that person, if they have passed
away or if they're unrepentant, is
forgiven, but that breaks the rights
that that curse has to be passed on. And
without without being weird, like a lot
of times it's easy to go, okay,
witchcraft curses or, you know, voodoo
curses. It can be as simple as
rejection. I did not realize in my life,
I had a generational curse of rejection.
My dad grew up feeling rejected. So, he
did not know how to show love and
affection to me. And because of that, I
grew up feeling rejected and I didn't
know how to show love and affection to
my children.
>> I didn't want my children to grow up
feeling rejected. And when you feel
rejected, often we look for something to
make us feel comforted. And that can be
drugs, it can be sex, it can be
pornography, it can be video games, it
can be romance novels. We're looking for
an idol to comfort us. So that that
spirit of rejection or that curse of
rejection, I've got to break that and I
have to do it in faith. And that by by
reading God's word, then I know that
that is broken. And then there's another
promise too. The Bible tells us that if
any person be in Christ Jesus,
I am a new creation. You are a new
creation.
>> Amen.
>> Old things are passed away. passed away
means they're dead. The dead know not
anything. Hallelujah.
>> All things are become new. So if I'm in
Christ, that stuff is gone. All those
curses or generational curses are gone
and broken. But I have to claim that and
believe it. And when we believe, faith
is what sets the captive free.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. I I think one thing I wanted to
say um because I kind of wanted to to
tell people all the different ways
that's dangerous.
Um, so we talked about the movies and
everything else and I wanted to say I
think people don't don't realize too the
danger in um
alcohol even they think I'm social
drinking
>> like I don't alcoholic I just do it
>> you know once in a while or whatever and
I don't think cuz
it's it's it's it's it's a dangerous
thing the alcohol I
It was something that we did, you know,
in our rituals. It was something that
was promoted.
I mean, yeah. And even the possessed
people drank heavily.
And I think I wanted to say for young
people
that that is that is there's a danger in
it.
And um sometimes if you're struggling
with it, it's not just because you're
struggling
with the thing itself.
It's there's a demon attached to it. And
you have to, you know, you have to ask
the Lord and he will how I, you know,
how I became free. I asked the Lord to
tell me the truth. I did not know what
the truth was, but I said, "If you're in
heaven, tell me the truth. if you're God
that everyone talks about, tell me the
truth.
And um
I just wanted to say that I didn't know
what the truth was. I didn't know about
God the Father, the Son, Christ dying
for me. I just wanted to be free at all.
Someone can just You don't have to say a
big elaborate prayer, you know. You can
just ask the Lord for the truth. Ask the
Lord to tell you if you're not sure even
what we are saying today. If you just
ask the Lord to let him tell you what
the truth is, he will tell you.
>> Amen.
>> And he and and you can be free.
>> That's a good point. I mean, um I think
people don't realize and recognize
enough like God says, "Come, let us
reason together." Right? test him,
>> you know, give him a chance and and and
say, "Lord, uh, you know, I I I I want
to see you work in this area. Um, you
know, I'm laying it on on on the table
here, and God will not ignore you."
>> Yeah. Amen.
[Music]